one hops on them in the more we have
great acceleration if you put your mind
to it you can be the first at every
traffic light you don't podesta fast and
quiet through the city Daniel Tomas
works with electric cars among the first
time you sit in an electric car it's a
whole different feeling it's a lot of
fun they're fast and maneuverable
because they're small it's like driving
a go-kart daniel has a job driving car
sharing vehicles from where clients have
left them to where they're needed and
especially to charging stations thought
of em oniony when you hook up the
charging station people ask what's that
an electric car what do you do with them
how long it's a date to charge I'll Park
in your drive cool all this week so
there's another charging station by the
way an electric car will only take you
150 kilometers between charges even less
if you turn the air conditioning on this
short range is still the biggest problem
with electric vehicles they have to get
back and be plugged in and that's Daniel
Torres's job the battery in this car is
down to thirty percent power before the
complete charge takes six to eight hours
we have to estimate because it's not
precise short ranges and long charging
times but multi-city the car sharing
subsidiary of the satoya car
manufacturing company says electric cars
are nonetheless attractive for urban
traffic its customers drive an average
of just five kilometers so the company
can have an all-electric fleet we now
have 350 electric cars each cost us 25
thousand euros and we have the team
servicing them plus logistics the
navigation systems the card readers to
open the cars the parking fees we pay to
the city it adds up to substantial sums
in the tens of millions or initiating
the neon buys car sharing with electric
cars costs the operating company notably
more
and gasoline-powered vehicles would
that's why other car shares haven't gone
in for electric cars Germany's biggest
car rental company sixth collaborates
with BMWs drive now subsidiary only 40
of its eight hundred cars are electric
sixth views an all-electric rental fleet
as unrealistic as they are not the flu
it's too early I can gradually add them
to my motor pool but I'd never make the
mistake of relying a one hundred percent
on this technology that would probably
scare off some of the customers and the
charging station infrastructure isn't
adequate yet in Berlin big enormous
dolls Daniel toma's already has plenty
of work with multi cities 350 electric
cars and next year the company will add
another 150 vehicles more electric cars
in the city will mean readjustment for
everyone those mega come come papa
bicyclist came around the corner and he
assumed he'd hear any approaching
vehicle but this is a silent electric
car I was barely able to dodge him and
not run him over as a driver you have to
keep in mind that you can't be heard
good luck with
car-sharing customers pay 28 cents a
minute to use an electric car a car that
[ __ ] and span is part of the service
Daniel also takes the cars to
maintenance where their electronic
systems and batteries are checked the
battery is the car's most expensive part
you want to take a look whether there's
anything else to be done here what's the
tool is the kinetic from yours will
start unless it so Daniel is already
looking for the next car that urgently
needs recharging ok good see you in two
hours take care let's go